Les réseaux de neurones sont une classe puissante d'algorithmes d'apprentissage automatique
et ils se déclinent en de nombreuses variantes
il n'est pas possible d'accorder une attention suffisante aux réseaux de neurones
dans une vidéo d'introduction
comme celle-ci. Ici, nous allons seulement identifier quelques composants clés
d'un réseau de neurones et le flux de travail général
pour comprendre comment l'informatique quantique peut contribuer
le réseau de neurones est un graphe connecté de neurones
un neurone est simplement une entité qui contient un nombre
et ce nombre est souvent appelé une activation, pour savoir
si le neurone est actif ou non
les neurones sont organisés en couches
et la première couche est la couche d'entrée
et la dernière est la couche de sortie
entre les deux se trouvent des couches de traitement appelées
couches cachées. L'activation de la
couche d'entrée est simplement chargée directement depuis les données à analyser
comme le niveau de gris des pixels d'une image
les activations de la couche cachée suivante sont déterminées
par les neurones de la couche d'entrée
et par des poids symbolisés par les lignes reliant tous les neurones
de la couche d'entrée à tous les neurones de la
couche suivante. En d'autres termes, on détermine l'activation
d'un neurone dans la couche cachée
par une somme pondérée de toutes les
activations d'entrée. On peut
aussi appliquer un biais, un décalage
on pourrait vouloir activer un neurone
dans la couche cachée non pas si la somme pondérée est simplement
positive, mais seulement si elle dépasse un seuil élevé
on applique ensuite souvent une fonction complexe pour obtenir une activation
entre zéro et un, comme une tangente hyperbolique
ou parfois une autre fonction, une
unité linéaire rectifiée. Tu n'as pas besoin de t'inquiéter
trop de ça pour l'instant. La seule
chose importante à noter ici sur ces fonctions
c'est qu'elles sont non linéaires
de sorte que le réseau dans son ensemble contient à la fois des composants linéaires
et non linéaires
la même somme pondérée des activations, cette fois-ci
en partant des activations de la
première couche cachée avec les nouveaux poids
se propage jusqu'à la couche cachée suivante
cela continue jusqu'à la couche finale, qui est la sortie
la couche de sortie contient des neurones correspondant aux
catégories, et les activations nous indiquent
à quel point le réseau est certain de la classification
ainsi, les catégories de sortie dans une analyse d'image pourraient être
chien, chat, hamster, et ainsi de suite
et une activation de 0,95 sur le
neurone « chien » indiquerait un haut degré de certitude que
l'image représente un chien. Tu pourrais initialiser ton réseau de neurones
avec un ensemble aléatoire de poids
et de biais, ou à partir d'une configuration de départ connue et raisonnable
mais l'idée est ensuite de vérifier
dans quelle mesure ton réseau de neurones classe les choses correctement
et de l'améliorer. On utilise une fonction de coût pour décrire
dans quelle mesure notre réseau de neurones s'écarte de
la classification correcte. Cela implique de calculer la
différence entre la valeur réelle d'une image
par exemple une valeur de un sur le neurone
pour chien et zéro sur tous les autres neurones de sortie
et les valeurs prédites
on somme sur toutes les catégories
on suit ainsi non seulement si la bonne catégorie a été
la plus activée, mais on peut aussi
vérifier si les activations incorrectes sont réduites
on somme ensuite sur tous les exemples de notre ensemble d'entraînement
pour obtenir un coût. On fait ensuite varier
les paramètres comme les poids dans chaque couche
entre tous les neurones et les biais sur chacun d'eux
des routines d'optimisation classiques sont utilisées
pour chercher un minimum local dans la fonction de coût
si rien n'est fait pour réduire la complexité de cela
tu peux imaginer quel
espace de paramètres astronomique on a mis en place ici
considère un réseau de neurones conçu pour analyser des images avec
seulement mille pixels. Ce réseau de neurones pourrait avoir mille
neurones d'entrée, une seule couche cachée
et une sortie binaire comme chat ou chien
c'est le cas le plus simple possible
et cela correspond déjà à mille fois mille
soit un million de poids entre les couches d'entrée et cachée
et encore deux mille entre la
couche cachée et la couche de sortie
potentiellement aussi environ mille
biais. Donc ce réseau de neurones simple correspondrait
à bien plus d'un million de paramètres. Cela dit, pour être honnête
les algorithmes modernes font généralement des simplifications
dans les réseaux de neurones classiques
et des domaines entiers sont consacrés à rendre cette minimisation
possible et même efficace
mais le fait demeure que c'est un problème de très
haute dimension
et l'entraînement d'un réseau de neurones
peut être très chronophage
et coûteux. Un réseau de neurones quantique, ou QNN,
fonctionne en commençant par charger les données d'entrée
puis en appliquant des quantum circuits
correspondant aux poids entre les couches
et enfin une couche de mesure
quelques points importants à ce sujet : le chargement des données
et les pondérations sont des opérations linéaires
mais les mesures sont non linéaires
ainsi, comme dans les réseaux de neurones classiques, on a
à la fois des composants linéaires et non linéaires
de plus, les weight circuits
ont toujours des paramètres variationnels
donc il y a toujours une minimisation classique à effectuer
bien sûr, cela n'a fait qu'effleurer la surface des réseaux de neurones quantiques
mais nous espérons que tu vas continuer à apprendre sur les applications
des réseaux de neurones quantiques
et d'autres applications de l'apprentissage automatique quantique
avec IBM Quantum